as you know scientists have a duty to
not let politics affect the research but
one northwestern university professor
saying in a wall street journal op-ed
that it's happening he writes this
scientists corrode public trust when
they pretend to have authority
on social and political matters
we thought our next guest the author of
the new book the dying citizen would be
perfect for this topic victor davis
hansen joins us now senior fellow hoover
institution nice to see you victor
morning to you science is to be
respected and explored we all know that
it's also to be questioned to make sure
that the science is correct how do you
see the position of this professor here
well i think he's absolutely right what
we've done bill is we've entrusted these
unelected people bureaucrats with
judicial legislative and executive power
so dr fauci
practices what plato called the noble
lie so
wear no mask wear one mask wear two
masks and when he's caught he said i did
it for your own good so you wouldn't buy
all the mask up and doctors wouldn't
have them hurt immunity 60 70 80 percent
i kept changing the figure because the
science was necessary to adapt to show
you that you still had to get vaccinated
and the worst of course is as people
pointed out is natural immunity was as
comparable or superior to acquired but
he didn't want to tell you that because
he afraid that the citizen might say
i'll take my chances and get covered
it's i'm under 60 it's 99 plus and i
don't think they should do that but he
was afraid of that and then they would
get culver and not have to take the
vaccination and get superior immunity
but how absurd is dr fauci because if
you get vaccinated he's saying uh
if you have coveted you still have to
get vaccinated so the people in colvit
are saying well if kovat
acquired immunity is superior do i have
to uh do the people who are vaccinated
have to go out and get coveted so they
have double protection like you want me
to have double protection so they and
then you know this is common bill we had
those 1200 health care professionals in
may of last year swear that the mental
health concerns of the blm protesters
were more important than violating
quarantine violating social distancing
violating mask wearing and you know it's
really
i'm really disgusted with this i think
everybody is they don't like these noble
lies if that's what the term is james
clapper when he lied if you remember
under oath and said the national
security agency doesn't surveil people
and then when caught he said well i only
gave the least untruthful answer are
those 50 retired cia expert scientists
whatever we use said hunter biden's
laptop is probably russian
disinformation and they did that because
they thought it was noble
not to see uh joe biden lose the
elections i would just argue these
people are very dangerous if the science
takes you in a different direction you
have to change your position your
feeling on that in this piece that i
mentioned by gary saul morrison
he writes that last year in montana's
glacier national park they had to remove
signs that said the glaciers would be
gone by the year 2020.
that that's an irony there uh into
itself
now the governor of texas greg abbott
had a breakthrough case with covid and
just this week he signed an executive
order that would ban the max vaccine
mandate
now
assume that his
position is based on science
how do you feel about a governor of a
very large state like that taking that
position
i think what he's saying is that i have
informed citizens and i serve at their
bequest and they're rational people and
they're going to make a decision that a
if they're under 60 and it's very
unlikely they're going to die from covet
and they may prefer to take their
chances rather than to get a vaccination
i didn't do that i don't recommend it
but i'm not going to tell somebody that
acquired immunity
is not as good as a vaccination when the
science says otherwise because i'm
nobody gonna lie to them and hope
they'll get otherwise vaccinated and
that's what he's trying to tell people
that i'm gonna give you the facts and
let you make the decision because i
trust your judgment more than i do
anthony fauci's remember anthony fauci
is a person who routed 600 000 dollars
through echo health and some insane idea
to promote what was really gain of
function research at the
biology lab in wuhan which was ground
zero the pandemic and he still denies
that it's gain of function research a
citizen wouldn't do that nobody would
elect a representative to do that only
somebody who's unaccountable to the
people has that latitude and power and
yet we're not supposed to get upset
about it i mean he to this day he won't
tell us why he routed that six hundred
thousand dollars or whether it is or not
getting a function and the side the
science suggests that he's incorrect
fair point uh mike gallagher
congressman's coming up in about 45
minutes on that very topic about wuhan
and what the access is or is not faulty
once said
if you're seeing attacks on me quite
frankly those attacks are on science
um his quote victor davis hanson thank
you
we have a lot of we have a lot of cult
figures and religious figures throughout
history that said if you doubt if you
dare doubt my word then you're an
apostate or you're irreligious so he's
treating science as a personality cult
and a religion that's wrapped up in his
own persona and that's as about as
anti-scientific as you can be he should
be saying look at the data
use the scientific method and then see
if i'm on the right or wrong side of
science and make your own decisions
based on logic not trust me i'm a cult
figure fair points vdh thank you victor
davis hanson nice to see you sir thank
you for coming